你的心里预期是，
我都给你们家生了双胞胎了，
我都放弃我自己年薪40万的工作，
我都给你的儿子在这个城市里面都立住脚了，
我的户口在这儿，
你儿子才能有这个户口，
孩子才能有这个前程。
但是你有没有想过，
凭你自己的能力是没有办法给你的孩子奔这样的前程的，
凭你的能力是没有办法在这个城市立足的，
你是借助了公公婆婆的160万才在这个城市里面立足，
脚的痛苦是来自于你对于公公婆婆的期待值太高了，
我现在自己在创业，
我是双胞胎女儿，
女儿是三岁，
我爱人呢，
她是分尼彩的，
她是属于那种就学校里面直接分配的那种，
公公婆婆在帮我带娃。
哎，
要说到我们婚前的时候，
我自己的工作经历是我在第一线城市上班，
是做教育行业的，
差不多28岁的时候吧，
年薪差不多是40万左右的一个样子的，
因愿介绍坚持。
我老公嘛，
当时因为我们那个行业也面临着一个动荡和改革嘛，
加上我的公公婆婆呢，
她是希望不为了家庭，
他们家条件比我们家好，
公公婆婆非常强势，
他职业出我们家的条件，
不用你上班的，
不用你操心经济的，
你就只管比家庭为重，
其实我有自己的资金嘛，
因为我工作这么多年，
我从来不敢休息，
再加上我的职业一直有一些瓶颈嘛，
我当时不无反顾，
就跟我老公到这边来了，
我们有一个共同的一个共识，
因为当时我们在那个新一线城市的房价，
他有一个摇号的政策，
摇完之后呢，
比如说可以低价。
啊，
但是他的市场价特别高嘛，
也有这个考虑，
包括我老公的工作呢，
比如说我的户口是在第一线城市嘛，
他其实比较向往这个城市，
他还可以以后通过我的户口就跟着我到这边来，
这于所有的考虑，
可能他跟我求婚的那种目标就特别强烈嘛，
当时我也有点恋爱脑了，
反正我没有考虑那么多，
过来了之后呢，
当时我们是说好了要在我那个地方就买房了，
其实我本来自己有一套自己的小房子，
我一个人住是没有问题的，
但是他不能居家，
就我想着既然你家有这个条件，
那我就一定要在这个地方扎根，
就过来之后呢，
他爸妈就开始有，
有时候我们不要在那个地方买房，
是江浙后面那个新一线城市，
但我老公的工作，
因为他没办法选嘛，
他在一个山区，
他做的是科技方面的一个，
但我们结婚之后买房子，
她爸妈就开始有一点想反悔，
我老婆还是比较坚持了，
因为她应该知道自己的目标，
最后我们是买了房子，
花了我全部的积蓄，
花了80个，
公公婆婆花了160个，
买房的时候我，
我婆婆是承诺我房贷是他们出的，
后面就是我也不爸妈对我的要求，
第一个来这边过家庭生活嘛，
第二个就是生小孩，
在这边半年之后呢，
我就生小孩了，
所有一切的矛盾就在生小孩这期间了，
我发现这种我没有任何话语权，
同时婆婆的一些育儿观念跟我有激烈的冲突，
我开始迫于家庭的压力，
我八个月的时候出去上班，
就是工作期间，
因为我体力不是特别好，
可能工作的不是特别出色，
跟那个老板的理念不太合，
我最后我就自己去创业了，
创业目前是一年半的时间，
我大概。
嗯了60个左右吧，
嗯，
太棒了，
我从生小孩到现在的整体的那种发生的事情，
我就觉得就特别委屈，
也是这别事情迫于我才跟您联系，
我在孩子半个月的时候，
因为我们孩子双胞胎，
而且我老公的工资是有限的，
他们又是过敏的体质，
所以他们奶粉钱基本上一个月要1万多，
而我们基本上就没有任何的闲钱可以去生活了，
我是基于所有的经济都没有帮助了之后我就自己去上班了嘛，
就是我知道了，
自从我出去上班，
我老公就让我公婆停止了对我们房贷的支持，
我觉得他没有经过我的同意就特别的生气，
有一种特别大的委屈感，
为什么是我做大了我所有的事情，
但是他们可以不兑现她的承诺，
而且还是我老公他去做的这样的决定，
你老公是独生子女，
他还有一个弟定，
他这么做的目的是什么呢？
他会发想摆脱他爸妈的控制，
因为他说他拿了他爸妈的钱，
他就要去低头嘛，
因为在这个过程当中，
其实我经常会因为一些育儿的问题去跟他吵架，
因为我关现我每次给他反馈问题，
他都解决不了，
就在和稀泥了，
他就觉得应该是他爸妈给了我们支持，
他可能就想着不要他妈妈的这个帮助，
我觉得你老公这个作为真的很可笑，
你要是你跟爸妈要划清这个界限的话，
那你把爸妈的160多万都还给爸妈呀，
我是觉得我牺牲了很多陪伴孩子的时间，
因为我公公婆婆是他们带娃，
其实不太注意嘛，
因为老一辈嘛，
我是因为自己的一些原生家庭的经历，
我就会比较包容我女儿的情绪，
这。
嘛，
但是我为了去替他分担一些经济压力，
我就义无反顾，
其实我的身体很差，
很虚的，
其实我觉得我的努力好像是一个笑话，
我觉得我的问题就是第一给予我的一些认知，
我也觉得是不是我再让他们拿房贷是有一点很好的嫌疑吗？
我一方面又觉得我在捍卫我自己的权利，
就我到底房贷我要不要继续争取呢？
嗯，
坦率的说，
这不是你的权利，
因为所有的承诺没有就落到实处的时候，
他都是放屁嘛。
在我们看来啊，
其次，
公公婆婆确实出了160万真金白银，
他也没有义务出这个钱，
但他出了，
所以说你要说到权利的话，
确实这个不存在权利的概念，
从法律上来说，
他承诺要给你还房贷，
但是没有公证，
没有白纸黑字的去公证处去公证的话，
他也是没有效力的，
所以从权利上来说都谈不上，
你现有的这条件来看，
这日子还能不能过下去，
如果你老公跟你，
你俩感情还是可以，
还是一条心，
现在还有人帮你带孩子，
这日还能往下过。
因为这件事情啊，
其实我是跟我公婆婆大闹了几次，
但是我最终也没有取得一个很好的结果，
我说其实为了这套房子我也付出了所有的积蓄嘛，
其实我们年轻人也没有那么多的积蓄，
我只要这几年的时间你们帮帮忙缓和了之后，
其实我们不会说继续要爸妈去付出的，
我跟你说啊，
有的时候转念是在一瞬之间，
这一瞬之间就在于什么呢？
第一，
这房子当初是谁执意要的，
我跟我老公吧，
是你和你老公执要买。
那你们为这个房子付出钱是应当应分的，
但是老人为这个房子付出钱是老人额外的，
这并不是老人的法定的义务。
再说的难听一点啊，
姐妹这话真的很难听，
这老人又不是只有你这一个儿子，
我还有个小儿子呢，
我又不是说指着你这个大儿子给我传宗接代，
所以老人出这160万的话，
不是老人应当应份的，
是你们执意要求的，
是在你们铁了心的要在这个城市生活，
然后把老人嫁在那儿了，
老人不得已出了这160万的，
你要搞清楚逻辑哦，
还是我们结婚的时候是谈好的，
我都跟你讲了呀，
姐妹所有的东西承诺这个东西他不值钱啊，
其实是因为我生了两个，
我在怀孕的时候，
我还没生的时候，
他们就在计划，
我婆婆自己的妈妈，
她生了两个双胞胎嘛，
她那个年代是顺畅的，
所以她当时叫我顺畅，
就说到时候断奶3个月之后就可以再怀一胎，
我就特别接受不了吗？
直接跟她说我不想生了，
所以是因为这里面也有很多的矛盾，
我是觉得他们家太重男轻女了，
我想给我女儿争取一些东西，
是这样的姐妹啊，
还是那句话，
转念就在一瞬间，
你想给你女儿争取东西，
如果说你本身自己就很有能力，
你创业你能赚钱，
你赚的钱都给你的女儿，
天经地义，
但爷爷奶奶的钱她想给谁就给谁，
这个没有办法，
我也痛恨重男轻女。
我也痛恨爷爷奶奶偏心，
但是这没有办法，
法律上来说的话，
他赚的钱，
他用他的血汗换来的这些资产，
他愿给谁是他的自由，
而不是说我现在就开始，
呃，
算计一下爷爷奶奶有多少财产，
我要给我的女儿争取多少财产，
这个方向是不对的，
方向应该是我算一下啊，
我现在能借助哪些人帮助我拉扯孩子，
我自己能挣多少钱，
我将来挣的钱我都给我的女儿，
这个方向才对。
举个例子，
你生的两个闺女，
如果爷爷奶奶的老二生的是孙子，
假设爷爷奶奶有1000万的资产，
如果爷爷奶奶将奶把他1000万的资产都给他的孙子，
咱们在法律上是没法跟人家打官司的，
没有办法打官司。
说啊，
你必须要公平一点，
我两个女儿也要1/3 1/3这么开，
没有这样的基础的，
法律没有赋予我们这样的基础的，
谁挣的钱谁说了算，
谁挣的钱他愿意给谁给谁，
这是法律赋予他的权利。
一面放下，
万般自在。
我现在就是一门心思，
趁着现在有人帮我带孩子，
有人给我负担这些东西，
我就多攒钱，
我攒的钱将来我想给谁给谁，
甚至你的两个女儿，
可能有一个人跟你投缘，
有一个人叛逆，
有一个人孝敬你，
有一个人不爱你，
那你将来都是想给老大给老大，
想给老二给老二，
这就是你的权利。
我的心态调整不出来，
你说的这些不知道为什么，
在这段婚姻当中有一种特别。
强烈的那种牺牲感，
我不知道怎么去调整这个状态。
牺牲感来自于你的预期，
你的心理预期是我都给你们家生了双胞胎了，
我都放弃我自己年薪40万的工作，
我都给你的儿子在这个城市里面都立住脚了，
我的户口在这儿，
你儿子才能有这个户口，
孩子才能有这个前程。
但你有没有想过，
凭你自己的能力是没有办法给你的孩子奔这样的前程的，
凭你的能力是没有办法在这个城市立足的，
你是借助了公公婆婆的160万才在这个城市里面立足脚的。
痛苦是来自于你对于公公婆婆的期待值太高了，
当然他们也有错，
他们把你的期待值拉的太高了，
他们不应该在还没有真正的深入了解和接触的时候，
就给儿媳妇太多的承诺，
这是他们的错，
但是这两项错误比起来的话，
你的错误更致命，
因为你是把你的生活质量寄托在别人信守承诺这件事情上，
多可笑，
对不对？
其实我在这个地方就待的比较难受吗？
因为这边是属于大山区，
他们的单位虽然是在市区嘛，
但是因为我老公，
但基本上是一个月才回来一次了，
从孩子出生到现在，
基本上都是我跟我公婆在一起生活嘛，
可能我自己的原因吧，
这方面的原因，
就这样的生活，
我觉得我我是挺没有意义的，
不是姐妹有意义，
意义在于什么？
女性的基因得到了传承，
这俩孩子是我的，
是我的基因，
我现在不管说。
通过什么手段，
用什么方法，
我为我的两个女儿，
给他们塑造了一个很多人不可企及的起点。
我在新一线城市，
不管我借助了谁的力量，
我借助了男人的力量也好，
我借助了公公婆婆的力量也好，
我总归是借助了这些力量，
为我的基因创造了一个新的平台。
女性的崛起就是一代一代的托举，
一代一代的托举，
才能让女性真真正正活成那种她想要的生活，
就将来你的女儿在你的托举之下，
在新一线城市就是他的起点，
天宽地阔，
她能过到她想要过的日子。
我原来看有一个韩剧，
妈妈是一个海女，
要钻到海底下去掏那些海鲜的，
这样一个到女儿这一代的时候，
就可以在大陆上工作了，
就是一个家庭的主妇了，
到孙女儿外孙女儿那一代的时候，
就可以去大城市去生活了，
就苦尽甘来，
你能够看到女性的崛起，
就是一代一代女性的托举，
为自己的女儿创造更好的条件，
为自己的女儿创造更好的舞台，
为自己的女儿创造更多的自由，
为自己的女儿创造更多选择的机会，
你做到了，
你很牛的，
你无论是借助你老公的力量，
还是借助公共博婆的力量，
你都做到了，
你在新一线城市立住脚了，
这就是意义，
你可以去看那个电视剧叫苦尽甘来遇见你好，
待会儿，
待会儿就去看一下这这件事情吗？
其实我对我老公有一些芥蒂，
归根结底吧，
我是觉得她为什么不跟我商量，
她的意思是我跟你商量，
你肯定不同意，
现在是这样子的，
我在这边的事业刚刚起步嘛，
其实我女儿现在三岁，
等到七岁的时候，
我们是要回到我原来的那个地方呢，
那我现在是否应该放弃这边的事业哦，
先过去呢，
不要你现在在这儿就做得很好，
你能够一年半就攒了60万，
就表示你自己这个人是能力很强的，
我跟你说啊，
孩子就是需要妈妈的，
需要陪伴的，
现在3岁，
3岁到七岁这四年的过程当中，
如果你不是陪伴在他们身边的话，
可能就错过了他们的成长的，
除非你告诉我，
你如果你回到那边的话，
你可能一年挣200万、
300万，
两三年你就把基础就打下来了，
有一种可能性的话，
那可以考虑一下，
但现在你已经很棒了，
既在这个城市立住了脚，
自己有了一份自己的事业，
孩子又相对来说健健康康的，
而且又有人帮你管着，
每天回到家了之后，
你可以看到孩子，
可以跟孩子聊天，
因为孩子大概3岁、
4岁、
5岁，
他话就特别多了，
他就要跟你聊天，
建立跟妈妈之间的那种关系了，
明白了，
因为我是准备7岁带孩子回那边去上学，
如果说我要去那边，
我肯定也是把小孩带回去的，
因为我妈妈她本来身体不太好嘛，
所以她可能的助理也没有很多，
我要不要跟我的公婆分开来，
让他们回去，
不要帮我带孩子，
没有这个能力，
现在经济上全。
盖吗？
包括房贷，
包括育儿嫂，
包括孩子的所有的支出，
你们现在有这个能力经济上全覆盖吗？
够是够的，
但是你说为孩子的未来做打算，
那肯定就不够了，
因为我的工作其实不是特别稳定的，
我并不是那种学校里的老师吗？
是自己就开了机构吗？
他们这边有一个特别是什么呢？
孩子一般小学以后都要去别的地方，
都不会在这个地方去放小学，
凡事皆有取舍啊，
如果说以你现在的能力还不够的话，
那你就得苟着，
就这么现实好，
就是这样啊，
拜拜，
做人、
做生意，
做合伙人，
都特别容易高估自己的贡献，
只看到自己的贡献，
而看不到别人的贡献，
这是常态。
每个人都这样，
或多或少每个人身身上都有这样的影子，
但能干成事儿，
能把一家人都粘合的很幸福，
把一家人啊氛围都搞得很好的人的话，
他往往会懂得抽离出来，
客观的去评价每一个人对家庭的贡献，
我讲这个话非常重要，
姐妹们啊，
你们一定要抽离出来，
客观的看一下其他人对家庭的贡献，
就像刚才这个故事的姐妹也是要抽离出来，
把你从这个故事里面抽离出来，
你看一下老人真金白银付出了160万，
老人实实在在的付出了时间精力啊，
每天的一日三餐，
打扫卫生，
给孩子洗澡。
伴孩子，
他实实在在付出了这些东西，
老公也在勤勤恳恳的工作，
也赚了钱了，
没有乱花。
从客观的角度来看的话，
其实他们已经都在为这个家庭做贡献了。
不是说光我一个人生了孩子，
光我一个人挣钱，
光我一个人陪伴孩子，
光我一个人为这个家做贡献，
要学会把自己抽离出来，
像一个上帝视角一样去看待每个人对这个家庭的贡献。
你勇敢的承认别人对家庭的贡献，
勇敢的表达你对家庭贡献多大，
你是这个家里的顶梁柱，
你是这个家里的精神支柱，
才有可能在你的粘合之下，
在你的这个组织之下，
把大家都团结在这个家庭当中，
继续为家庭做贡献。
否则的话，
一旦当我们只看到自己的付出，
看不到别人的贡献的时候，
别人就会有一种肉包打狗的感觉，
别人就会有一种我养出了个白眼狼的感觉，
我跟你说，
善良的人啊，
他不会变坏，
但是会变得无情。
记得点赞关注哦。